wind energy clean green good for the
planet but it isn't without its problems
when these wind turbines get old and
need replacing they're strong
lightweight blades often end up in
landfill
now a team of researchers are putting
forward a camera chemical solution
[Music]
wind turbines are a growing source of
renewable energy one report suggests
that across the world wind could soon be
providing over a terawatt of power and
that number could double within just
eight years but as the number of wind
turbines grows so does the issue of how
to decommission them
these enormous Hollow blades are made
from an extremely strong combination of
different materials including
lightweight glass or carbon fibers
embedded in a kind of plastic called an
epoxy
but epoxies are difficult to recycle
because they don't melt easily which
makes it hard to reform them into
something else and it's also tricky to
get all the embedded materials back out
so what do you do with old wind turbine
blades
among the many teams trying to solve
this problem are a group of chemists
from orhas University in Denmark they've
developed a novel chemical process that
can break down epoxies into useful
components something that up until now
no one has been able to do
in this test tube is a small piece of
wind turbine blade a solvent and a
catalyst called ruthenium all being
heated to 160 degrees Celsius
after a few days of heating the epoxy
has broken down and the team can
separate out some of the original
components
this is the metal mesh that protects the
turbines from lightning strikes
here are the glass fibers that were
embedded in the resin now easily
removable
in this tube is what the chemists were
really after bisphenol a a key
ingredient of epoxies and one of the
most expensive
and here you have a mixture of the
leftover plastic components
the bisphenol a can now be used to make
new epoxies and the fibers are clean of
plastic residue and strong enough to be
used in new composite materials
theoretically this kind of process could
be scaled up to break down epoxy
Composites not just from wind turbines
but also boat holes electric cars and
airplane wings and save them from
landfill
the new work could help make wind
turbine production a more circular
process with the recovered materials
going back into new blades but it's not
yet ready to scale up the current method
is energy intensive and the ruthenium
Catalyst used is expensive the team are
now looking for ways to make the
ruthenium more active and stable so that
they can use less of it
meanwhile people are looking for other
ways to make use of this waste whether
that's turning them into playgrounds or
fences or even shredding them to make
cement
future turbines could also be made of
more easily reusable materials
but it's been estimated that by 2050 the
world could have 43 million tons of
decommissioned wind turbine blades to
deal with so these researchers are
hoping that a new chemical solution will
help make a wind-powered future even
greener
[Music]